hi my name is Isaac Berle oh and I'm
from Houston Texas I'm an amateur
screenwriter I watch them Kerch all the
time when I'm at work or I'm at home I
enjoyed a video enjoy all the lessons
that the the screenwriters give you
producers give you all the knowledge
that the talent that the active give you
the directors give you everything I just
hook it up like a sponge because I enjoy
everything or every aspect about
filmmaking but like I said I'm going to
add an amateur screenwriter so I think
the favorite one I ever saw was from
Eric Dyson when he was talking about the
the hero's journey and whatnot and it's
something I kept I watched a video like
20 times it's something that I think
that my screenplays are missing in
structured character character driven
things like that well it really makes me
think behold all the videos make me
think the envy was really I really loved
to interviews I love pretty much
everything about the whole channel I
mean I watched the I watched a veal
every day but just for me to learn
because in my life I want to achieve
putting my stories out there I don't
want to change Fame and riches like
there's anything wrong with riches but I
still I want I want to do something and
put my art out into the world I want I
want to show my son that his father can
do it you know I want to show him cuz
he's a he likes stores too he write
stories he's 18 he's autistic and he
looks up to me as my zero and I I want
to do something for him to show him that
it's possible and you guys are showing
me that it's possible for a regular
person just to you know make it a do
something and I want to put my are
doctor into work
and I want to do a lot of stuff in my
life but sharing my art and sharing my
stories to the world is one of the best
things that I can hopefully hopeful do
and I'm and then they'll courage give me
that courage to do that through the
channel have seen the different people
making it and how do they make it or
what pitfalls that they did to stay away
from and and whatnot so yeah yeah gives
you courage and I have courage and I'm
i'ma keep going to keep right and I
write every day so thanks a lot guys
enjoy